three two you are now one step closer to
riding in a Hyperloop Hyperloop one just
successfully tested its propulsion
system out in the Nevada desert it's one
of several companies racing to realize
the futuristic transportation method
they all have the same big dreams to
make neighbors of distant cities replace
fumes spewing trucks with
planet-friendly freight movement and to
dodge the massive costs that come with
railroad construction this is the first
successful use of a custom-made
full-scale Hyperloop component the
linear induction motors spread over
nearly 200 feet of track fired a test
vehicle up to 120 miles an hour in just
the second and a half that sled reached
300 miles per hour before victoriously
plowing into a sand break it's an
important step but the journey has just
begun
Hyperloop one still has to figure out
how to build the tombs through which its
pods will travel how to keep those in a
near vacuum state and how to make the
pods levitate and that's before it
worries about how to build and operate a
commercial system without going bankrupt
it may seem like a pipe dream but
whichever company Craxton technology
first could genuinely shift the world of
transportation
just like the ship train automobile and
plane did all those years ago